MEP s voted for cars on European roads  to be cleaner by 2030 car makers will  have to cut their fleet wide co2  emissions by 40% on-demand platforms  will have to feature a 30% quota of  European content new rules on  audio-visual media will also protect  children from violent content and apply  stricter rules on advertising Parliament  decided to cancel 70 million euros of  pre-accession funding to Turkey the  country has failed to make improvements  in the rule of law democracy human  rights and press freedom members have  set their priorities for the October  18th  EU heads of state meeting in Brussels  the summit will focus on brexit  migration and internal security only 1.1  percent of criminal profits was  confiscated in the EU between 2010 and  2014  MEP s voted on new measures to make the  confiscation and freezing of criminal  assets quicker and simpler